It's easiest to complete the square when solving a quadratic equation, if this
quadratic is not factorable and if a is equal to 1 and b is even. We want b to
be even because eventually we're going to add b over 2 squared to both sides of
the equation. If b is even, then we know that this b over 2 squared ends up
being an integer rather than a fraction. So, once we know a equals 1 and b is
even. We can move this constant term to the other side of the equation. This
will put the equation in this form. Next, we add b over 2 squared to both sides
of our equation. This allows us to rewrite the left side as a perfect square.
And then we can continue solving using our square root method. When solving the
problems throughout this lesson. Use these steps as a guide to help you
complete the square. Try solving this first practice problem. Move this
negative 6 to the other side, and then complete the square and solve for x. Be
sure you enter your answer using the plus or minus symbol. Good luck.